[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host grace helbig
very excited
to be talking with i can't believe it's
taken this long to get her on the
podcast christy carlson romano in this
episode you probably know her from all
the hits even stevens kim possible cadet
kelly well she's busier than ever right
now we talk about all of the content
she's making uh
christy's kitchen throwback on youtube
her walk and talk videos on youtube
where she talks about and reflects on
her
wild life in entertainment uh and her
relationships with all your favorite
disney throwback stars i learned that
there's a 90s convention coming up that
she's hosting very soon and she also has
christy's kitchen throwback the cookbook
that's coming out this spring we talk
about literally everything uh and she
gives me some really
amazing insight into motherhood and also
into content creation she's just
absolutely lovely i could have talked to
her for hours and hours uh but we had to
keep it concise so please enjoy this
episode of not too deep with christy
carlson romano
[Music]
okay and we're in christy i'm so excited
to talk to you about everything how are
you
i'm doing okay you know today was a
rougher day than other days um i just
got back from uh like a
10-day work trip but wow
anybody who travels with kids thinking
that the work trip's gonna be
i don't know a regular kind of work trip
it was like well it's a long time we're
not going to be away from our kids so
let's like
bring them
and we'll stay near the in-laws and you
know you try to like
set yourself up for success yeah and
more times than not you're disappointed
um i'd say about 90 percent of the time
you're disappointed
which actually is pretty good statistics
when you think about the 10 of the time
being awesome because yeah
it's just you're not the the the the
odds are that someone's gonna melt down
at the wrong time and it's gonna be
traumatizing so that's true you live in
fear constant
uh fear and
you make parenting sound so lovely
i have a dose of birth control whether
you realize this or not i am a walking
embodiment of birth control
amazing i do appreciate your honesty i
think it's absolutely wonderful um i'm
also just curious
like you've been on this work trip you
have a billion things going on like is
there a normal day for you or is every
day completely different
yes every day is completely different um
to my chagrin i guess you would say i i
am like
i covet structure
i covet like consistency yeah because my
entire life has been very
uprooted um
or at least it's felt uprooted to
someone who's just i think
more or less like me yeah
of its structure so um
i'm sure i could have probably ended up
becoming more of a producer or something
you know in which case maybe my life
would have been a little bit more
structured but i think
the way that it's panned out for me
becoming a content creator as you know
there's just really no structure in that
um i mean there's batching content right
where you bash your content you try the
best you can but especially if it's like
guest dependent like we had trouble
sort of like figuring out times and
places and i i tried to value
myself
as a creator to be pretty
dependable so
it stinks when you let people down and
um there's a little bit of there is
always just a little bit of like
desire to
to have your stuff together yeah like
you're like yeah i'm making content but
i still have my stuff together i promise
no you seem like you're
a person that very much like you said
strives for balance and strives for
structure in what could be a completely
structureless uh work world
since it's entirely up to you but then
you also have to leave room for
creativity and inspiration and
availability and all these things that
aren't as reliable or certain all the
time
yeah
i'm very curious
uh
how you ended up in entertainment take
me through
you were very young when you first
started how did that how did did you
just always know
that being creative or an artist or
acting was something that you just like
couldn't deny inside of you
yes i believe so and it's funny that i
see some of that in my youngest daughter
and my oldest i have two daughters right
so one just turned five one just turned
three and like the five-year-old loves
like
talking about germs and she you know is
very interested in like sciency stuff
okay so i see
with both of my daughters they're very
different personalities right and i
think a lot of like what i'm
triggered by these days is like wow like
when i was this age i was you know i had
my union card or like you know
you you talk you start to kind of
reflect you know about when you
sort of do something competitive at a
young age and so my two daughters are
very different one is very much more
like at the moment at present she's very
science-minded and then the other one's
just like princess i want to wear i want
to dance i want to be like this little
like you know
little thing this little feminine thing
or whatever and i'm like great that's
who you are this is who you are i must
have been
my mom said that i was precocious
um but my sisters were doing pageants
and dance competitions and all that
stuff so
i kind of just traveled along i'm the
youngest of four
and slowly
but surely
i i got a manager like at one of the
national talent competitions and then i
did the commercial circuit you know and
wasn't really
i guess they wanted
more like it was at a time when there
was like you're the blonde you're the
brunette you're the you know and it was
like very specific
and now it's a lot more inclusive and i
think it's just very different i
remember at one point i was actually
cast because i had a last name romano
somebody assumed that i was like latina
and they hired me in a
in a spanish-speaking
um
favor shoes commercial
and one of my earliest memories working
as a child
was sitting on this woman's lap who was
supposed to be my mom she was like back
to school shopping and she was speaking
spanish and like i was like i didn't
know what was going on there's a camera
there's this woman speaking another
language like
some weird some weird stuff
but yeah i remember that for sure wow i
mean it must be
this rings very true in all the content
that you make now that seems very
reflective of your
um
experience in the entertainment world
and very like introspective about
different things i'm curious
what uh
was the inspiration to start making
especially your walking and talking
videos i don't know if you uh
you've created a genre
so it's just
very
cathartic apron is that what your other
that's a nice way of being like christy
what is this content i feel like there's
it's it's so like calming in nature like
literal nature
uh
i'm curious what was the
like was this an idea you had or was
this kind of something you
someone presented to you or where did
this come from
i never have somebody present an idea
for me
somebody presented an idea for me
because i'd be like yes okay let's do
this i i think i used to have ideas
presented to me
and the traditional you know traditional
hollywood was like yeah let's go take
this out and you know yeah shop it
around town and it's like
useless
wastes of time they call it the water
bottle tour and it's just like why like
this this dog and pony show it's just
ridiculous and then i think eventually
my husband was on his own track you know
he got his master's degree at afi for
writing
and wanted to and was working with like
some really major major production
companies to do his own stuff and again
he did the whole dog and pony show and
he's like this is frustrating and i was
like yeah this is your life now like and
you'll be lucky if you sell like a
couple things like a handful of things
and then you'll be lucky if those go and
and he's he felt like me he was like
look i've been in the military like i've
traveled the world like this is not the
end for me i'm not just going to like
settle
or doors closing my face like i'm going
to create my own opportunities and you
should too
and so like we
i think came to with you to each other
with a deeper appreciation
for the industry that we both
individually experienced and
when i met him he wasn't even in the
sort of
the absolute like nexus of it like we
moved to la together and then got
engaged okay and but originally met
when i went back to college at 26. yeah
and so it was like i saw him go through
that growth that i went through from the
time i was six and struggled with my
whole life wow and so eventually i think
i said to myself look like i don't know
where the any of this is gonna bring me
i don't know what anyone's gonna say and
yeah these were just the cooking videos
i was doing yeah i was just like but i
have nothing to lose
um
and i think like
you know it's hard to say that
until you take that leap right like you
like you know you yeah you you make that
leap from traditional to
doing it for yourself and then it's
almost like you never really want to go
back yeah it's very it's i'm sure for
you like i never really had i think feet
in the traditional world too much but i
still felt just such a i always thought
you were a huge star like and i still
think you're a huge star when we work
together on much music yeah yeah oh my
music yeah yeah oh sorry my music yes of
course no it's crazy how many people had
uh
were in that show in hindsight and i've
seen i know that was like lit i remember
being like oh my god i'm gonna sit down
next to her and play this incredibly
obnoxious person and she doesn't know
who i am as a real person to understand
how different this is from me uh but
here we go but i i the that was one of
the projects that i had first done that
was most similar to a traditional like
set and
i had
and had production and all of this stuff
but it did also give me an appreciation
for the independence that making your
own content has and it's very kind of
like spoiling when you
don't have any gatekeepers and you get
to just put out whatever you want i'm
sure for you this has been like it's
very cool to see like you be yourself
online and i wonder if there's like
if you're surprised by the the feedback
or the
response to it
i think i'm not surprised by most of it
but i was surprised about how in the
current state of the world
the knee-jerk reaction is judgment and
it doesn't even really have to make
sense so like sometimes people will
comment on stuff and what i've realized
now is that
hey you really don't need to read
into the negative comments like
obviously it's good to engage with
people and it's important
but
to take to heart you know username 1159
you know
my shorts like you know like you're not
gonna like
think about that person and be like in
the middle of your night like they come
be like oh no
he thinks i'm unhinged like
it's the weirdest thing like i've seen
even on twitter which you know i always
say to people like look if you're
looking for your high school bully
they're on twitter and they think
they're really funny yeah oh absolutely
that's i've really not used twitter at
all and i think about oh maybe i should
and then i open it for a second and i
realized no it's chaos over here it is
cr
it isn't it's strange how it's just like
communities are drawn into certain
databases and for whatever reason the
way that the software is laid out or i
don't know how that how and like in tick
tock like that's something that i've
been
fostering and probably growing the most
and the fastest on yeah i think
like it's really fascinating to see the
communities
there it's a much more open-minded
community it's also like it's whoever's
fyp like i have a certain fyp though so
therefore i'm exposed to a certain kind
of tick tock side
i'm sure that somebody who's like you
know alt-right is going to have a
totally different fyp and a totally
different
community
but
tick tock is interesting in that the
community is very
uh supportive of whatever your i guess
whatever your fyp is whereas like with
twitter it's almost like you sign on and
you're you have to assume that people
are going to come after you oh yeah
yeah twitter's got this energy that's
like [ __ ] prove it
so
and i'm just like i don't really need
for my mental health to be having to
constantly prove myself to everyone
but i do feel like and i'm just
on the beginning phases of understanding
tick-tock but the like you said the
energy there is to me very reminiscent
of the beginning of youtube energy where
everyone's just kind of like doing
whatever they want and throwing a bunch
of spaghetti at walls and seeing what
sticks and everyone's just kind of like
here for the journey for everyone well
it blew up during uh quarantine and
people were just doing silly stuff to
feel connected and and less chaotic and
the moms of tick tock which is kind of
the one i think the community that i
identify with the most
it's cool because like you can learn so
much about being a parent
uh who's wanting to break generational
trauma and you know discipline their
child not with you know
actual fear-based stuff and then like
there's also a side of it that's like
glamorous moms show you how to do your
makeup fast or like
you know it's like there's all it can
service you in so many ways outside of
being a creator so i'm not just a
creator
i comment this is another little trick
that i've learned and
i can't really compete like i don't
dance and i'm not making like king bach
kind of like original content with like
a crew a hype house crew or whatever
like i'm not doing that kind of thing
yeah um and i also what i've realized
too which we can always chat about like
doing deep dives into like understanding
your brand and like all that stuff
because i've certainly kind of really
become
more in tune with all that which i never
would have done had i not kind of
branched out on my own yeah um but like
for me
i comment on people's uh
like stuff uh and so yeah if i can't
post
i just make sure that i comment
because that's interesting
yeah um
hold on one second yeah and do your
thing hold on one second
we're good guys we're good oh good i'm
getting a very transparent look at mom
life right now
it's very fun yeah i think you're right
i think like i think like it's okay to
like display that i don't get to show
that side of myself
because i it's funny because when we
talk about like the branding thing i
don't think people are interested
in me
displaying authentic mom hood as much as
they are
and honestly i've done deep dives into
this so like i can see what is retaining
like what people are actually watching
and what yeah
you know
and and it's okay
that people don't necessarily see me as
the go-to
everyday mom and so
it there is this there's this split
personality that i've had to have for
even the sake of tick tock which one
would think
is the more authentic like oh this is me
without makeup and this is get ready
with me and
but the thing about tick tock i think is
that the
the concept is like here's where i start
in this video look at how great i am
after
um look at what i can make myself become
you know like always like this
transitional thing yeah yeah yeah and so
with motherhood you're pretty
consistently tired and you're pretty
consistently like worn down
i don't think there's much content that
can be made about that than like
there's my starbucks order
hey guys once again exhausted uh
it's a roller coaster i can't get off
exactly well i am interested to hear
your thoughts about
building a brand for yourself online
because like you're you come from this
world that you know kind of i assume
tries to tell you who you are or put you
in categories of this is what you can
play and this is the kind of parts you
can do and then when you go to make your
own content you get to be yourself
exactly as you are i'm curious
you you seem very like thoughtful about
what you're creating for yourself online
is that like is that conscious in
everything that you're making is
representing yourself
as a brand in a certain way
great i mean that's awesome that's a
great question uh i think that like i
said i think
there's
there is a split personality there
and for me i mean look motherhood is
very isolating
and like you can
become you it's also very
you can also grow quite a lot yeah
so but there is a there is something
that people don't talk about which is
like mourning the death of the brand the
personal
brand you used to be yeah you know if
who used to be was like oh i'm traveling
the world and you know it's it's just
you're not that person anymore unless
you decide you want to be that person
with a child you know if you thought
that through for yourself which by the
way i feel like most people don't
know well enough
yeah do you think
how
how much being a parent is going to
affect their their daily life um because
i think it's because either they don't
have
a comparison or
you know they just haven't been through
it so there's really no judgment you
know what i mean like for for how when a
parent says to me like oh i know i'm
gonna and there's jokes about this on
tick tock where it's like when i hear
somebody who doesn't have kids say that
they're gonna make sure their house is
always clean and like etc and you kind
of are just like laughing yeah but
i come from the place of like just like
everyone just do your best and just you
know be as good as you can to your kids
um what was the question again though
it's about about i guess just building
your brand online because i do think one
of the things that at least i notice is
like your transparency like you do talk
about struggles you do reflect and and
think through and talk through things i
think almost in a way to kind of
give your
your truth but then it also like the
byproduct of that is it's helpful for
people that are experiencing things
similar to that or that weren't able to
realize what they were experiencing or
how they were feeling uh until they
until they see or hear something that
you've been through that's probably the
most rewarding thing so like when i'm
recording them to speak to your your
previous question it's like
i'm remembering
who i used to be right who i am now is
very different yeah and so when i'm
talking about it there's like this like
healthy distance
um this privileged viewpoint from from
where i was and so a lot of people
in
talking about my brand i had piloted if
you want to call that or i tried out
some content which i remember youtube
said in the initial phases of starting
your youtube channel like try it out try
out many different things
now you're not really rewarded so much
with that because
you know the views in order for what you
in order to have a view it's like they
have to watch at least like a minute
it's like it used to be a couple seconds
when you know youtube was in its early
stages
and then the views were so the views
were super high and then of course
people were getting served to more
people so then their
their subscribers were super high too
and so now it's like just to get the
view you have to be so authentic and you
have to be saying so much stuff
in in just a thumbnail too right yeah so
it's like so this is what's got me a lot
of attention on the walk-in talks
because what i did prior to the walk-in
talks was a bunch of cooking
celebrity collaboration stuff with
disney channel stars and it was very
straightforward and
i really have a soft spot in my heart
for it because it's what brought me to
the table of you know people talking
about me again or being like hey there
she is i wonder where she was
but when it came to
you know covid quarantine
oh my gosh you know it's going to be too
hard to keep booking these celebs now we
have to offer the money um
wait there's fires outside of my house
like
i think we need more space let's go to
austin and then it's like well what do
we do now
um so we tried react videos right as
like a different format yeah and it was
just plateauing and it just wasn't
feeling like anything was really
like
i guess hitting
and it was it was starting to be less
and less authentic was what it was
and so when i when i work with my
husband i think he's a really good he's
very critical
and so
that's great
very critical he was a marine or is a
former marine so like extremely critical
and he he's a quality control guy so if
something starts to you know he's like
look this isn't even worth
investing the time and the money into
any of that so let's like just you know
move on
and then he and i both put our heads
together to think about my my brand or
like what people want to see and what's
working
yeah and so when when we sat down
what i had piloted on youtube or tick
tock sorry
was like hey this is your big sis
checking in mental health something and
it performed very well yeah and the
engagement was really good and so it was
on brand for somebody to look to me and
be like oh yeah she's the big sister
type so we kind of put two two together
and a another person i knew was like hey
um
you should really try to be vulnerable
vulnerable is what's gonna be that's
what my therapist says too
it was not my therapist
it was actually someone
who is big in the world of digital
content and has done like these really
big videos
um and and and he said like look this is
this is what got me to where i am maybe
this is all for you
interesting yeah
yeah and it's like what do you have a
value because you see this too a lot of
times where like content creators are
like hey if you're starting out like
these are the things that are going to
post
the best or you know as long as you're
providing value to people
then and i was like what is my value and
so if you look at your life as being
somewhat valuable
yeah i i wouldn't so the other thing is
i wouldn't necessarily think of my life
as valuable to others because i'm i
i actually tried to be very quiet and
and humbled by any experience that i've
had and keep it to myself for a really
long time
and so i never really thought to stand
up and be like oh well i support this or
oh you know yeah yeah who i am this is
what i'm struggling with and so
therefore people just had this very
frozen
picture of me in their mind from a very
specific time in their adolescence
really
and so
we tried the walk and talk format out
and it was like
like the floodgates kind of opened up
for people
it was kind of crazy it was like
every week i was
i was
really kind of exploding on the
like the whole news
reels and stuff like that like yeah yeah
yeah
constantly coming out with stuff and i i
found it amusing because i was like
really this is it this is what's gonna
this is what it's gonna
be okay but it's it's cool because like
you said
people have this image of you in their
experience with you which is very like
two-dimensional and very frozen in time
for them to to experience you as a full
person
with uh you know stories and thoughts
and feelings about things i think
reminds people like oh people are human
beings and this is more fascinating
maybe than the image i had in my head
about this person yeah i think it's
really cool um
we're going to take a quick break um and
when we are we at that point we're at
the quick break point
okay and when we get back i want to talk
to you about the cooking we got we have
a cookbook coming out we got all kinds
of stuff happening so excited i just got
the pictures back from the shoot that
was that where it just was and it was
nice
so fun so yes talk about all that okay
we'll be right back with more not too
deep after this
[Music]
okay talk to me about this cookbook
what's going on how did this happen
thank you for asking me i'm really
really excited because i haven't been
back shooting
christy's kitchen throwback which was my
first format on youtube yeah and it has
a very special place in my heart because
the idea of comfort food and comfort tv
shows and things that people grew up
with it just felt very
it just felt very personal to me in my
life experience to share
to continue to share from those episodes
something in uh in a book and cool i i
think it's going to be really great for
the fans of that era and the whole y2k
thing is extremely big right now like
you just saw the super bowl like
halftime show
and i felt really old actually though i
don't know about you yeah that's what
melissa and i were just talking about
that i was like yeah every millennial
watching this halftime show was like oh
this hits the sweet spot but also
we have uh reached a certain age haven't
we i think so man i think it's like when
you start thinking about like boycotting
watching euphoria because you're like
cause i don't like what that promotes
you're like oh no i need to
get a colonoscopy
exactly
um
i'm always curious uh for
making something like a cookbook which i
have no experience with but i'm
fascinated by how you create your
recipes what's your process like for
that well we've already created the
recipes which is why this was a home run
from the get-go um
you know these recipes live in
perpetuity on my youtube page so
essentially just combining that whole
experience during that show
which the recipes are on and then we're
offering 10
new celebrity recipes
cool and
a bunch more like you know
ecto cooler high c punch like throwback
kind of like oh fun 90s 2000s recipes
that really are fun to investigate when
you when you look and you start to
scratch the surface there's so much that
was recalled when we were children
that is pretty wild to be like what was
i just shoving into every
in my mouth all day long no wonder i
haven't
i still don't understand pop rocks like
i still don't know how that works and
why
that is legal but yeah exactly but there
probably will be some pop rocks in there
too because i remember we need some pop
rocks kickballs or something i don't
know nice so
so yeah all of it's already to be made
into a book and then there'll be extras
and they'll be behind the scenes
uh articles and interviews and stuff
like that yeah and then as i took
pictures
with the celebrities
uh who i'm getting them to like sign off
on
you know the fact that originally they
came on for the youtube show and i
mentioned to them as we're taking our
photo for the thumbnail i was like hey
we're gonna do a cookbook too wouldn't
that be fun and they're like yeah
i'm like i'm coming back
oh that's great
um
and when does this come out in the
spring
yes it will be out in the spring right
now there's a pre-sale link uh that we
can send you and then cool there's a
pre-sale link on my instagram and um
probably my tick tock or something but
awesome christy's kitchen throwback yeah
very cool and it's i mean it's
an offshoot of something that you've
already successfully built but it's also
just like a very cool like tangible
piece of content that people can like
spend time with versus just like click
and move on and click and move on
yeah i think for the real og fans you
know
who've lived through that and that that
are lo they don't really have a lot of
things like this to serve them yeah true
though the gal that's editing my book
her name is nikki martin she's really
great
she did she edited and co-authored the
book with jonathan bennett from mean
girls
called the bird the unofficial burn
cookbook great and so it's going to be
very colorful it's going to have amazing
beautiful pictures of this food that was
by the way amazing and fun to make
during it but then it was great to taste
it again
and
it's like a piece of nostalgia in your
hands like you said so it really is a
wonderful book that i think
i think will so well with a certain
audience and maybe you can gift it and
re-gift it and gift it to people so
sweet
i love that something to look forward to
yes
very exciting too is the 90s con that
i'm about to um host in hartford so
hopefully i'll have one in hand
at least like a fake one to like show
people oh my god 90s con sounds so fun
it's gonna be pretty quick
um
i'm so jealous and i gotta look that up
after this
literally have okay so they've got like
boy bands there
got
every single cast of every single show
like you've ever thought of amazing
party of five and
doing and i'm
i'm hosting it so yeah that's crazy i'm
doing all the panels and i've never done
anything like this before i'm usually
like a guest at comic cons and they're
like well you'd be really cool to host
it i'm like okay
because i've got a damn girl the whole
time
and then they have like literally they
have like you know they have like
costume museums
on tour and stuff like that they
literally have the spice girls like
clothing
like in a yeah amazing oh amazing okay
well i'm gonna let that
stew in my head for a little bit
[Music]
not too deep
now i'm going to move on to the
questions i ask every single guest
that's on the podcast oh yes um the
first is who alive or dead would you
most like to throw cold spaghetti at
i mean that's an amazing question
and just to kind of clarify is that
uh my assumption is that this is just
your answer in this moment this is an
answer that can change obviously
day to day hour to hour etc
hold spaghetti oh my gosh this is gonna
be so funny
oh my god
oh my goodness
and it's entirely up to your intention
it can be
um
it can be joyful it can be um
humiliating whatever you prefer
oh my gosh okay honestly i don't like
keep i don't like to have to keep
talking about this person because we're
not in touch and there's no ill will
towards this but i would say
that i would throw cold spaghetti and
shia
only because
only because okay when we were kids and
we were doing even stevens he literally
threw a bunch of tomatoes that were
covered in paint
at
red my character because she was like
singing some opera flashback thing and
like the idea was that she's booed off
stage by people throwing tomato batter
and i literally like i can't believe
this is to say the producers
handed him a bunch of tomatoes and he
just sort of like maniacally throwing
tomatoes at me and i was like you mother
and i never got him back he team peed my
dressing room he was such a punk but he
was a cute kid and um i would still
throw spaghetti at him yes okay
i mean he
yeah it's just a response he started it
so you have to finish it somehow finish
it somehow yeah um okay the other
question to ask every guest is to tell
us your worst pant [ __ ] story or
like a bathroom emergency situation
however you can only use three words or
like small phrases to describe the
situation um
so for example mine is
oh perfect mine is college jogging front
lawn
okay so i love that you already have one
go ahead you ready for
this okay
um
it it's uh
i have two different ones okay okay i
have two different really awful ones
humble brag all right full brag
i love that we're doing this oh my god
um
napa
zebra shorts
oh no
yeah
it's a very specific image
and then the the next one is um
crush
skirt
oh
um
dad
oh
progressively worse
[Applause]
both sound like core memories um i wish
i could forget each of these but yeah
thank you for sharing therapy grace
yeah this is cathartic
um okay our last little section of the
podcast is called deep and hot uh where
i have a deep question for you that
we've prepared and also
uh i'm curious about your hot take on
kind of like a subject that we've
prepared for you i love all of this all
of this yeah so a deep question for you
is when
did you learn to look out for yourself
oh my god i'm still learning to be
honest so it's kind of a question um
i i probably
honestly
i would say
yikes okay
when you ask a female this question it's
hard because they they have to learn
progressively
how to advocate for themselves yeah and
so like i've legitimately learned to
advocate for myself
you know i think when when i stopped
drinking when i was pregnant i really
started to
hold myself accountable yeah for like
ever my actions and like my past actions
and then what i could do to be a better
person on a day to day so like that was
my first
you know foray into that experience and
then i think i learned how to advocate
for myself
um
uh when i had my second baby
i went into early labor
and it was because somebody had uh come
into our home and my baby and me all my
first baby and me my toddler i guess
had like a stomach flu and so i was like
taking care of my my daughter in the
bath so of course i got it and i was
nine months pregnant
and so i went into early labor and
they were like i had a doula and the
doula was like
on call or whatever because uh
god i'm glad i had her but i didn't have
her i didn't have one the first time so
the second time i had heard like doulas
help you and guide you through the
recovery process etc
and so
i had to call the doula because they
were like look we're gonna we're gonna
give you pitocin we're gonna start we're
gonna pop your bag like you're gonna go
you're gonna have this baby wow and so i
thought that i was
definitely
going to have to have the baby but
once they start to give you that like
the drugs and stuff
you don't know like you could end up
having a c-section just because you if
it's not your time and it's early yeah
then there's complications so
um
i called the doula and so i had to like
really make a stand and advocate for
myself and i and it was an uncomfortable
feeling because a
i was in the process of being
traumatized by already doing this early
and had really gotten sick up to the
point where i
started being dehydrated and having
those contractions as if it was labor
wow but as it turns out
i could have probably not had the baby
then
but she told me on the phone this is
your choice at this point
and so i i knew who to reach out to to
call to advocate for myself
and i do believe that so much of
learning to
advocate and understand what you need
and take care of yourself
is about
when to pump the brakes when when to
really it's about that control of
yourself and sort of like
just kind of sitting back and
checking in with yourself
rather than just kind of acting and
you know yeah
listening it sounds like you really took
a chance to give yourself permission to
like slow down and listen to yourself
in that moment yes
i still have a lot to work on i think
you're a great listener oh god bless the
uh but i i'm with you that i think as an
adult too and uh being a female that
like
you and especially like being in
entertainment you do so much to like try
to serve other people and try to provide
stuff that you forget
that it does require
time and commitment to like
take care of yourself
100
yes crazy you can't you can't serve
people from an empty cup i guess right
beautiful love that
i must have taken that from somebody so
i won't take that um okay last little
question uh curious about your hot take
on
the idea of like rediscovering yourself
we've kind of talked about this through
this whole episode but it feels like
with all the work that you're doing and
like you said when you had your kids
there's like this death and rebirth kind
of moment where you you lose a part of
yourself but you know you become someone
kind of new um i'm curious
what your thoughts on on rediscovering
yourself are
i think
i was seeking mentorship for a long time
and i feel like mentorship is this thing
that
you're told is easy to find like you
assume that mentorship is everywhere
around you when you're young because
why wouldn't one of some why wouldn't
somebody want to help you like why
wouldn't they
take the time but i think when you go to
college they try to explain to you like
look no one's going to just mentor you
you have to like work hard for that you
have to like
intern you have to assist people like
there's all that stuff but when you're
in the industry
mentorship looks like paying a casting
director to do like a workshop
mentorship looks like
you know
i don't know dating somebody because
they're an agent and
like they can help you with your career
um and maybe you don't want to date that
person but like you know
you know look at i mean honestly look at
julia fox yeah yeah on a hot take like
julia fox
is claiming to be like kanye's muse and
is that true or not we don't know but
like
he's certainly mentoring her in some
regard as he did the whole kim thing
uh and i'm not like big into that whole
like i don't have like a
a dog in that fight so to speak you know
like but it's a hot take in that like
mentorships
are either healthy or they're not
healthy
uh i always kind of wanted mentorship
uh i i found a little bit of mentorship
at disney channel but not enough for me
to feel like
it was
unconditional
reliable yeah
yeah i mean that's the thing is that a
lot of the mentorships in hollywood are
like
for a phase or like
it's very hard to be like oh yeah i've
known that person for 20 30 years and
it's so rare
to
for that to happen and so
you know um
i think that mentorship in is is really
important so like i have found that
i've gotten mentorship in collaboration
with my husband yeah um
i found everything that i needed with
him as a partner which by the way like i
did not expect that to happen most
people can't work you know as closely as
we work yeah um and and how frequently
we work together and
it's really great to see him grow in his
own way and his own brand and his own
like um
like skill set and stuff like that in
the digital space of sales and all that
stuff like it's such an interesting
market and he's like doing so great
and then for me
to have a bounce board
to talk about this branding stuff with
and
it's all about making good content at
the end of the day but if you don't
really truly know what you're doing and
you're not talking to somebody it's very
long i gotta say it's probably really
lonely yeah totally
i mean i
to so identify with that and it's like
you said that you assume mentorship
might be easy to come by because why
wouldn't people want to help each other
high tides raise all ships but it is
that true like deep sense of connection
and trust with someone is rare and when
you do find it like
hold on to it
you guys seem like you really deeply
love each other and support each other
it's very cool
we do i think at the very least
christian the very most we drive each
other crazy but you know it's
valentine's day i say i love them there
you go i know this has been i feel like
i could talk to you for like a billion
more hours on everything but we have to
we have to wrap this up um
okay but uh as a token of our
appreciation we like to give our guests
a personalized horoscope from us to you
uh we are not astrologers at all so um
you know take everything with a grain of
salt melissa put it in the chat if
you're able to look at it and read it
aloud to the class oh my gosh you're not
even kidding me
okay dear pisces should i do it in an
accent whatever you would like
okay
all right and there's a there's a bad
word in this too oh yeah you can you
don't have to say the bad word okay
dear pisces
fish of the stars being born on the 20th
you're on the cusp of fire sign aries
so although you may be a dreamer at
heart and you want to live in your head
you're you face many outbursts of
frustration when outsiders block those
dreams from bringing reality
give the haters a real dreamy fu
while you're at it
that's a great one thanks
it's in the stars you got it
yeah no that's that's cool
yeah we we like to throw it in at the
very end
now christy where can people find you
and everything that you're up to they
can pre-order the cookbook as well where
can they find you if they don't know
already okay okay so guys please go
check out my youtube please subscribe if
you haven't it's a lot of fun i do lots
of crazy stuff there and you can also
watch all of the cookbook recipes unfold
with celebrities from all your nostalgic
days from lalane from lizzie mcguire to
jaleel white from you know family
matters i have such a range of awesome
people on and we cook all of the foods
from their shows and their careers
amazing so that's a blast the cookbooks
pre-saleing for spring the spring
release stay tuned but then i've just
i'm about to launch two more podcasts um
which will be viewable like yours right
on on you know youtube and then probably
available on spotify and all those
streaming platforms uh the two podcasts
are pretty great
which i would love to chat about but
maybe on another another time another
place yeah
one of them is going to be called
vulnerable which will be an offshoot of
the mental health stuff i've been doing
with my walk and talks amazing
and that's with guests
so uh we have alison stoner as one of my
first guests great um yeah
we have uh
scientists and we have all these amazing
women and men that are coming on and
talking about their journeys and mental
health stuff and then we have uh another
podcast launching called
i hear voices whoa i hear voices is not
mental health believe it or not it's um
it's literally with me and
my my old sidekick but not my sidekick
my co-host will fredell from kim
possible oh great
and boy meets world
and we are interviewing the most iconic
voice over actors of all time oh that's
awesome so we actually had eric bowser
on who plays marvin the martian who's on
your shirt yeah that's amazing
yeah and so that's launching soon i
believe
like march 4th cool it's like our first
big thing with that and
you know
it's it's all just trying to make some
great content right like yeah trying to
do the next big thing well awesome i
mean you sound like you're doing it
there's plenty of things out there for
everyone to enjoy something for everyone
yes yes thank you thank you so much of
course thank you christy i hope you guys
enjoyed this episode as much as i did
and i hope we get to keep talking
because there's still so much
that i want to know uh we'll see you
guys next time on another episode of not
too deep goodbye
too deep too deep too deep not too deep
with christ
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen lani eunice
post-production sound by chris henry and
an extra special thanks to flula for the
theme music